Turkiye, not Turkey.
This English language campaign announced it to the world.
But why abandon a name that's been around for 100 years?
President Recep Tayyip Erdogan...
...said the move was to best represent the country.
But some say the change is to distance the country from links to the bird,...
...as well as the alternative dictionary definition...
...of something that "fails badly."
The association with the bird genuinely annoys Erdogan and the people around him.
It's not a surprise, given the government's sensitivity...
...to how the country's perceived and fondness for nationalist rhetoric.
That, of course, is at the very center of this policy as well.
Their claim is that, the word "Turkiye" conveys Turkey's eternal spirit...
...more than the English word.
As Turkey bids to expand its international footprints...
...from military operations to popular TV series,...
...the government has become increasingly image conscious.
This is part of the new, confident, powerful Turkey in their imagination.
They really want to make a push for new Turkey on the international stage,...
...and this is part of that package.